you know Jordan Peterson he's actually
one of our most viral videos reacting to
his takes so there's a speech he gave or
something on why people are so tired all
the time and today I took a nap for an
hour and was pretty tired so I was like
[ __ ] seems like pretty good time to
watch this I'm sure a lot of people go
through the same thing eating their [ __ ]
diets terrible sleep schedule my sleep
schedule is just dog [ __ ] what I was
tired all the time I nap about two hours
a day and now I don't nap at all I can't
believe I can wake up in the morning
that's never happened to me in my whole
life what is fatigue it's the lingering
tiredness that's constant it's an
unexplained exhaustion because it
happens even when you've spent the day
doing nothing sometimes you wake up from
an eight-hour sleep still feeling tired
or you may notice you're not productive
at work or at home things might feel
overwhelming for you on a day-to-day
basis there are many reasons this might
happen an almost two-year pandemic could
be one cause
social unrests the climate crisis and
political turmoil don't help the
situation
beyond that beyond the bigger picture of
world affairs something is going on on a
personal level we are creating
exhaustion for ourselves what do I mean
by that well first let's look at where
we come from humans have not evolved
much from our hunter-gatherer days we
used to be people who traveled in small
groups always on the go eating and
surviving from one day to the next like
any other animal nobody stayed in one
place for too long and they rarely
indulged in Feasts if they were lucky
enough to have a feast humans would eat
everything they could and keep moving
because they didn't know when they would
get to eat next
forward to today our DNA still believes
we're in the savannas having to eat
whatever we can to survive it's why you
clean out a tub of ice cream in one go
even when you know it's not good for you
your body wants to stock up on food is
that what it is when the Agricultural
Revolution came about and humans started
to settle down we started eating more
than we needed therein lies the problem
we've gone from eating perhaps once a
day when we could find food to eating
three meals a day and some days it's
three meals with evening and midnight
snacks peppered in the average
American's eating cycle lasts 15 hours
which means they start eating the moment
they wake up and their last meal is just
before bed and it wouldn't be so bad if
we were burning this food regularly or
even eating the right kind of food like
our ancestors our bodies find our food
hard to digest and its delay in
digesting prevents our bodies from
deriving the energy from the food
overeating the kinds of foods we do
fills up the tank but provides nothing
in return the subsequent weight gain has
an adverse effect on your quality with
those dogs out of mine overweight has
been linked to sleep disorders like
narcolepsy other than that increased
inflammation I thought this was Jordan
Peterson talking it is he'll get back do
you know what narcolepsy is yeah that
that's where you just get like crazy
tired throughout the day right no
narcolepsy is it's like when you're just
like straight up falling asleep straight
up fall asleep so uh grandpa said this
is just a narcolepsy side note Grandpa
seraphino's aunt had narcolepsy and one
time she went to the Canarsie cemetery
and uh she went she went to visit
whoever was dead in there and that's
where my grandparents are actually and
she she just fell asleep at the grave
she fell asleep but it was like late
afternoon so when she woke up they had
already closed everything up and she had
to go to the gates and scream for help
for somebody to let her out of the
cemetery at night which had to be fan
[ __ ] tastic for the people walking by
to have somebody in some old lady some
well it's I think it would be spooky to
have somebody locked in the cemetery
holding on to the gate saying let me out
of here help me I think it's hilarious
spooky and hilarious that's a horrible
thought great oh my God yeah she's been
dead for probably 30 40 years now she's
gonna come knocking soon leads to high
blood pressure sure diabetes issues with
regulatory functions of the body and of
course fatigue because inflammation
damages organs and tissues throughout
the body it requires energy to repair
energy that it's not getting yeah so you
should continue your body [ __ ] your body
has to work harder in order to try to
survive the [ __ ] that you're feeding it
and you weren't getting energy to begin
with so your net negative on energy yeah
it makes perfect sense you can eat as
much as you want if you're eating
healthy foods and you're working out and
stuff and you're being active yeah but
shouldn't food in general give us the
energy to work
well eating lowers something called
erection which is a neuropeptide that
regulates wakefulness and appetite the
more you eat the lower your erection
goes the more exhausted and unmotivated
you feel and there are only about 10 to
20 000 neurons that produce a rexin in
our brains
erection is released throughout the
brain to affect certain behaviors
primarily this means regulating Behavior
needed for survival sleep wake
regulation mating and yes also food
intake but in certain regions of your
brain a rexin promotes seeking and
taking rewards rewards can include
alcohol food sugar and nicotine the
neuropeptide in turn is stimulated by
exposure to these substances and creates
a positive feedback loop basically the
erection receptor involved in your
thrill-seeking behavior is dependent on
the part of your brain that is
encouraging it it it's like parents
encouraging a particular type of
behavior if you get negative feedback
after breaking a window you're unlikely
to do it again but if you get positive
feedback for getting good grades you
want to keep doing the thing that made
them and ultimately you happy this
action promotes the use of the
neuropeptide so you continue seeking
food that will activate that positive
feedback loop and as you consume more
food than your body needs was that just
like really frustrating when I was just
like failing and just being a [ __ ]
with school oh my God it was terrible
because so kindergarten or even
preschool through sixth grade you had
perfect grades you took standardized
tests I remember one time the principal
pulled me into the office because on the
Statewide standardized test you got you
know 100 on both of like the math and
the English part like you you were just
you were just killing it never had a
problem we had class clown problems
where I always had to go in and you know
deal with autography in the principal's
office and talk about your personality
which I never gave you a hard time for
because I thought it was funny I thought
you were funny you still are but then
after that so I had this Superstar
student and then after that you turned
you just did not you you just didn't
give a [ __ ] and it was everything was a
fight and when you did well and I would
be like good job you see doesn't it feel
good and you'd be like
I don't care I could give a [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] could give a [ __ ] like you could
just give a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] geek
yeah no but you were you you did get
motivated with sports if you did well in
sports you got like oh yeah all right
I'm gonna keep going but you didn't give
a [ __ ] about academics and you loved to
learn things you just didn't want you
just don't do it on your own you just
wanted to do it your own you don't want
to be taught you want to learn your way
yeah I did not also like so yes it was
frustrating as hell knowing you had
potential to be amazing and academically
because you're intelligent and and you
just you have potential you [ __ ] geek
you were smart learning from Geeks about
Latin
a study published in the international
review of neurobiology proves that
erection neurons promote food-seeking
behavior for that positive feedback but
in the time before the neurons are
activated to seek food you see
productivity your erection levels are
elevated after a 42 to 72 hour fast if
you have a set schedule for eating your
erection neurons are more active
immediately before it's time to eat
meaning you are your most focused and
alert this changes when there is a
production of glucose in your body that
happens due to food intake glucose at
physiological levels reduces the firing
of erection neurons in a concentration
dependent manner this means that under
physiological conditions
erection is activated and transcribes
the neural peptide when glucose levels
are low like when you fast or restrict
eating and is inhibited when glucose
levels are high now this doesn't mean
you have to stop eating or more
drastically reduce your portions because
that can cause your body to crash yeah I
think that's why people do an
intermittent fasting where you only eat
like once a day that way you're staying
like laser focused and you just eat like
a bunch of steak and then get the
nutrients you need and then you're done
because I noticed like when I wake up in
the morning I'm way more productive like
right away and then I eat and I like I'm
just like
I just like slow down have you ever
noticed that or no you know it's well my
my body's changed I used to wake up
starving wake up like be woken up by
hunger and have to have breakfast within
15 minutes of being awake or I was
miserable and I I'm different now so now
I'm up I'm up for a few hours a couple
hours before I eat breakfast I've
noticed also since we moved here and
maybe it to Florida where it's hot and
maybe it's almost like a summertime diet
here I find myself eating less up in
Boston when it's the winter it's cold I
found myself like and maybe that has
something to do with this natural thing
these Natural Instincts that he was
talking about I found myself you know we
would eat heavier Foods we would eat
more maybe because we were in the house
we were you know just it was something
to do but I find that we're eating
really healthy here and less frequently
yeah we only eat like two meals a day no
yeah and we just have some snacks in
between so that helps with the freaking
gabagoo you need to do is eat the right
Foods so your erection levels are remain
relatively High keeping you alert and
fresh instead of tired and groggy for
that you need to cut out or at least
reduce foods that convert into glucose
in your body the biggest culprit here
carbs there's something wrong and what's
wrong [ __ ] I knew they were going to
talk about carbs this has been the
biggest thing that I cut out earlier in
the day is carbs and it's genuinely
changed my life it's cutting out cutting
out carbs until late at night or not
even like I really just don't even
really eat carbs anymore shout out
oscarvore that's my personal Health
Physician dude's helping me out he's
he's killing it with you and he's oh he
seems so nice he's a good guy got my raw
milk I'll meet him in Mexico and I'm
going in a month you going to Mexico
next month I didn't tell you no you
don't tell me
I need the dates because I need to make
sure I'm not planning other things I
can't tell you enough times you gotta
let me know I travel I do things and I
need you to watch the dog oh I gotta
watch the dog when he what what I'm not
telling you right now I got a couple
business things I gotta take care of
don't worry about it I don't care
I had to go but we gotta karate
frag and you didn't invite me
doesn't matter with you carbs there's
something wrong with the way we're
eating and what's wrong is that we're
eating way too many carbohydrates
carbohydrates are basically poisonous
when carbs are digested they turn into
sugar which fuels your body after eating
carbs your blood sugar goes up and the
body releases insulin which moves the
sugar into your cells to be stored and
used as energy and after some time your
blood sugar goes back down
if you eat a carb your body can't handle
your insulin production will increase
causing more hunger anxiety and yes
fatigue this also causes stress to the
body and in response to that stress your
body releases cortisol cortisol removes
the sugar from your cells and puts it
back into your blood which raises your
blood sugar if this happens maybe once
in a while it's no problem but when it
becomes a regular occurrence two to
three times a day your body releases
cortisol many times a day
release of a stress hormone a quick rest
in your room oh yeah bone causes fatigue
nearly half the foods we eat come from
carbs this includes both refined and
unrefined carbohydrates unrefined or in
their natural foods we don't have
include fruits the loaf of bread or a
cracker in this house and how weird is
that because we never you know we always
had that stuff I've seen frozen pizza
just for like emergency food in here if
when you made frozen pizza a couple
weeks ago I felt like [ __ ] after I know
because you just don't eat junk anymore
you don't eat carbs or and that [ __ ] has
sugar in it and it's not even like
physically I feel like [ __ ] like I just
can't even think I just turned into a
[ __ ] I can't write I can't do anything
just like Tick Tock it turned into a bot
but refined carbs include white sugar
fruit juices and flour most of the carbs
we eat today of course are refined cakes
rioche bread loaves a majority of what
we eat come in packets our ancestors
certainly didn't eat food like this they
likely got only 30 percent of their
calories from unrefined carbs while the
average American gets 50 of their
calories from any carbohydrates that's
20 percent more than our genetic
ancestors and from sources that are not
nearly as clean or healthy as theirs now
it doesn't imply that if you eat carbs
you'll be sleepy all the time body
builders for example load up on carbs
but you wouldn't pack them as sluggish
or tired that's primarily because they
eat a lot of protein
protein it turns out has the opposite
effect of carbs in that it increases the
erection levels in your brain what's
more scientists this is legit exactly
what I've been doing I've just eaten
being big ass steaks all day drinking
raw milk all they do is clean the
kitchen because you fry a steak I fry a
steak and then I have to clean the whole
damn kitchen because it gets greasy yeah
but I'm glad your brain's working city
of Cambridge have found that amino acids
which are common in proteins like egg
whites actually subdue the damaging
effect of glucose on your erection
receptors so if you can include protein
with your carbs you shouldn't feel as
exhausted anymore
along with portion control and eating
the right so protein and carbs so like
double cheeseburger that's what I hear
there wait what I didn't he said if you
include protein with your carbs and I
said double cheeseburger but that can't
be what he means no because I mean a lot
of the like that bread and [ __ ] is just
garbage too yeah it's [ __ ] if you're
eating it really is about the quality of
the of the ingredients you're eating too
eating within 60 Minutes of going to
sleep has a detrimental effect on your
sleep because your body is still working
on digesting your food and converting it
to energy get an appropriate amount of
physical activity in two it can be low
impact like walking for 30 minutes a day
or going for a swim you don't
necessarily need to lift weights or run
if you don't want to it might be
challenging especially if you struggle
with fatigue and body weight
even a moderate amount of walking will
work wonders and you will see a
difference in your overall mental health
and energy levels just be sure you take
medical advice before starting any diets
or exercise routines given your usual
physical activity energy levels weight
and fatigue get these dogs out of my
face
I hate that [ __ ] like the toes like like
going like that like you know what the
worst the worst part of the year is in
up north and when the spring and summer
comes and people start going to the
beach and posting pictures of their feet
I don't care if they're white or tan or
whatever I don't want to see your
goddamn feet to prove that it's summer I
don't want to see them I think everyone
should wear boots 12 months a year I
want to see your ugly ass feet or you
can go It Alone
you keep going you will find that it
gets easier the results will be small at
first but they will compound over time
if you remain consistent
if you found this video helpful you can
stay motivated with our content
subscribe to the channel for more and
hit the Bell icon it's a very nice video
but he did lie in the title there was
like 30 seconds of Jordan Peterson what
are you gonna do what are you going to
do it was good yeah Basics call it down
don't eat processed food balance what
you eat and move your ass that's it we
didn't need that 12 minutes for that
what are you gonna do all right well
hopefully someone gained something out
of that and they stop eating [ __ ] and
carbs all the day if not they enjoyed
maybe the story about the narcoleptic
ant who passed out in the cemetery all
right make sure to follow me on
Instagram where I post more exclusive
content follow me on Instagram too where
I've post pictures of the dog and stuff
bye guys what's up drop us up I learned
how to say that recently
[Music]
writing on the wall won't last long
[Music]